at the end of last term we'll get Ted to
a curve right in this process of
differentiation so there's a good chance
a lot of you and I'm hoping actually a
lot of you have been sort of chipping
away at that over the holidays but I'm
not going to assume that's the case if
you spent holidays anything like I spend
holidays so therefore the first thing we
do is just get back on the horse like
one of us what on earth is any of this
what's what's the point of it so let's
begin
what would first say is given a function
of X so let's define it like this if you
had a function of X and you call bit Y
ok so we know a lots of functions of X x
squared minus 3 sine X I X cubed plus 4
whatever these are all things where X is
the variable you put it in you get some
other number out given Y as a function
of X we can find what we call the
gradient function rights the gradient
function being that it was based on
gradient rise over 1 if we use this wide
notation we would say it's a change in Y
that's rise divided by a change in X
that's the run right the difference is
it's not just rise over run between two
points it's right over run at a
particular spot because they're
interested in a tangent right not a
secret between two points using function
notation rather this form dy/dx business
we could write this in shorthand as f
dash X and that's the way we would say
it right how do we find it we develop
this technique we called it first
principles do you remember that and it
was all based on rise over run we can
define we defined f dash X as okay now
think we had to introduce a bit of
heavy-duty machinery a new notation to
remember what the very very first thing
we had to write was to limit very good
near as H approaches zero okay what
follows is going to be based on
on waves overruns shown is a fraction of
some kind did he run river what's on the
top of first principles
yes go ahead yep okay fantastic pause
there so this is just rise yeah and
you're comparing the vertical coordinate
at some spot and the vertical coordinate
at the previous spot so this takeaway
that and then of course on the
denominator for one it's about the x
coordinates right so it's X plus h
takeaway X but of course the x's cancel
which leaves us just with h so we've
seen first principles this is great we
use this to have a go all different
types of functions but eventually we
sort of got to the point where it's like
the first principles kind of tiresome
you know we all don't like writing this
we even less like writing this and all
the expansions that come from that so
the things that the functions that we
dealt with right four degrees or so I
should say powers four powers and X
which were all the ones that you had to
deal with we developed ahead a little
rule which would get off straight to the
derivative would shortcut us through the
differentiation process without having
to appeal to first principles so if you
were differentiating some kind of power
of X any power of X X to the power of
some number what was the rule to you've
ever for your concern fantastic so we
are our short head away over every that
was you bring the power out the front
there is and then you reduce the power
by one i'm Kaduri awkward okay but then
we noticed okay i if you have a think
about certain kinds of functions like
they this we note binomial theorem so we
could just expand that out if we wanted
to and then use this on every single one
but no more we don't really want to
write like that the huge paid to have to
expand that all out get all the terms
out and then do your differentiation not
only that but there were some functions
like saying this we
there was no expanding to do right you
just know but I'll theory is not going
to help you here and so what can we do
to differentiate this guy so we
introduced a new rule to remember what
it was
chain rules very good the trade rule so
the statement of cheer all is very
simple it's if you've got some function
y there you can find the derivative with
respect to X by cheating together a pair
of other derivatives what were they to
robot yeah this is a really squeaky
Blackwell marker okay so do I do you do
DX perfect the whole idea here is that
the usual kettle giving you the result
that you need and in this case all you
have to do is introduce a substitution
you write in both of these cases what
would you be equal to okay so if we let
u equal so that inside function write
the 3 X minus 1 then this will become
this can be restated as u to the power
of 7 hours you'd restate this as yeah
very good so you guys have already gone
the second step I could have said the
square root of youth but of course you
know the power of 1/2 is more useful
because it shows you how to use this
rule right in this case D why do you you
differentiate this respect to you so you
differentiate this with respect to u can
you walk me through there all right
there what am I going to do power comes
out the front and then power reduces by
1 which in this case is negative 1/2
right and of course you could then write
that with this on the bottom and then
you replace you with whatever u was
equal to as we saw before okay